MEGHAN DESAI: Developers
using Bluetooth Low
Energy have a tough time today.
The stability is
inconsistent, and it
burns through the
battery, which ultimately
leads to your users are
unhappy with your app.
The good news is that at
Android l we're fixing this.
My name is Meghan.
I'm a product manager
on the Android team,
and I'm here to tell you
about two key improvements,
peripheral mode and
improved scanning.
Bluetooth Low Energy
is a low-power form
of Bluetooth communications.
It allows devices like your
Android phones and tablets
to communicate with
peripherals like fitness bands,
or Bluetooth beacons.
Your Android phone
in central mode
can scan for advertisement
broadcast from peripherals,
and it can also form connections
to exchange additional data.
Bluetooth Low Energy scans
first landed in Android 4.3,
and one of the
biggest drawbacks was
that scanning prevents a
device from going into standby.
If your app needs to scan
frequently or constantly,
say for nearby
Bluetooth beacons,
preventing your user's devices
from going into standby
will kill their battery.
And trust me, no one likes an
app that drains their battery.
In order to address
this problem,
we have offloaded scanning to
the background in a way that
allows the device to enter into
standby when it isn't detecting
advertisements from
nearby devices.
But at any given part
of your user's day,
their device may be bombarded
with advertisement packets
from the myriad of
devices in their vicinity.
This would still prevent the
device from entering standby.
To address that,
we've added new APIs
that make your scanning
even more efficient.
These APIs allow you
to specify filters
to reduce the number of
potential advertisement packets
your application
needs to process.
You can set filters
on specific parts
of the packet like service UUID,
service data, and manufacturer
data.
With these filters in
place, your user's device
but only makeup on
standby and tell your app
when it finds a packet
matching your filters.
You only get notified
if an Android finds
a nearby device you're
really interested in.
Your user's device will keep
scanning in the background
indefinitely until you
stop the scan manually.
But your user's device may also
be connected to other devices,
like a Bluetooth headset.
Starting in the L
release, Android
will optimize and balance
scanning with other activities
and power based on your request.
You can request to have
Android scan with low latency.
This will increase
how quickly you
detect a device you
are interested in when
it comes within range.
But even background
scanning consumes power,
and scanning more frequently
will consume more power.
If detecting the other
device is not time critical,
like when the phone is in
standby in the user's pocket,
you can ask Android to scan
less frequently and save power.
We've added peripheral mode too.
An Android device can now
act as a Bluetooth Low Energy
peripheral.
It can broadcast
advertisement packets
and form data connections
with other BLE devices.
In fact, your apps can specify
the contents of the broadcast
packet like service UUID,
service data, and manufacturer
data.
This allows your app to produce
more meaningful advertisement
packets for your use case.
But the space in an
advertisement package
is limited if another app
has already filled it up,
then there's no space for
your app's packet contents.
To fix this problem, Android
now allows multiple apps
to advertise
concurrently, allowing
each app its own packet.
If your app needs to
advertise more frequently
to enable other devices
to detect it quicker,
you can request low latency.
Of course, advertising
more frequently
will consume more power.
If your use case allows
advertising less frequently,
you can request low power.
Just like with
scanning, Android will
optimize how often to
transmit your advertisement
packets, balancing power and
other demands on Bluetooth,
such as scanning or a
Bluetooth audio connection.
Now, try out our improved
scanning a peripheral mode
support for yourself.
Thanks for watching.